it's gonna be a talk where I were
talking about flasks and I'm gonna be
talking about something like the key
things that I learned recently while
learning how to turn data science into
consumer product I know that's not the
sort of thing that like most data
science just get a chance to do but I
found it to be super rewarding and I'm
going to just talk a little bit about
that journey and share some tips and
tricks for how to work with that so so
my number one goal for this session is
to end on time because it's five o'clock
it's after five o'clock now and I'm sure
you're all really tired I know you love
Python but there's only so much you can
hear about Python in one day so I'll try
to keep it tidy timewise but I'm going
to introduce chopper owner and our
trending product service and so that's a
service that I recently built and so a
lot of these learnings are based on that
I'm going to introduce flask which is
really super cool framework in Python
and then I'm gonna share some advice and
very concrete examples for building a
production level system using flask so
first to introduce shop owner I don't
know if you any of you went to talks by
Hannah and Nicole where my co-workers
sitting here they talked about PI SPARC
and unit tests but we call ourselves
ourselves Amazon Prime for the other
half of the internet so we have six
million members and a growing network of
over a hundred and forty retailers and
our members get a bunch of great
incentives a shop they get free two-day
shipping or turns and great deals and
our retailer partners went out to the
way we do that is by adding a layer
JavaScript to their web sites that give
them a bunch of cool new features first
of all it links them with a bunch of new
customers through our shop runner
network those customers tend to be very
engaged and give them Crees conversion
rates and average order values and we
have a growing set of technology
features that go into that new layer of
JavaScript and
for example Express Checkout and we have
new mobile shopping app that's in beta
right now and launching at the end of
the month called district so here's
here's a sampling of some of the
retailers in our network so if you're
interested in trying out shopping for
yourself I have a bunch of free one-year
memberships up here so please come up to
me afterward and I can just give you one
so I'm gonna be talking today about some
very general lessons that you can take
away but the example for everything is
this training product service that we
built shop runner that feeds currently
three of our consumer products so what
we do is we take a bunch of data that we
have on how our customers have
interacted with all of our retailers so
across our network and we figure out
which products in our network are are
hot right now or trending and when you
save that data and database and we have
a flask API on top of that that then you
can query that and get a quasi infinite
feed of what's trending right now and
you can filter it on a variety of
different attributes so that you can
personalize it to the customer so one of
the things that's in is our new mobile
app district I have the district app
icon and a screenshot of what it looks
like so the trending feed is the main
landing page because a big part of that
app is shopping discovery trending is
also used in our members shop runner
comm website you can pick your favorite
retailers and see what's trending for
them and then we also have a widget that
shows you what's trending in different
cities that we can put on our retailer
partners websites and that's an a/b
testing right now so the stack for
training there are a lot of pieces of
technology that go into this and I'm
just gonna briefly touch on them but for
the rest of the talk I'm just going to
focus on this portion of this diagram
the web at piece but in brief we have a
bunch of data in a snowflake data
warehouse we
use PI spark on data bricks to
manipulate that data and figure out
what's trending we then store the
trending results in Amazon in AWS RDS
and on my sequel database those are very
optimized for being hit by an API so
it's much faster than using a data
warehouse solution like redshift or
snowflake and then we have a web app
built in flask they use the sequel
alchemy to query the database and G
unicorn is the web server in front of it
and then for all this we're using docker
containers using terraform to build
infrastructure we use Jenkins for CIN CD
and the app itself is built in Amazon
Elastic container service so who here is
familiar with flask okay a lot of people
so that's good
so flask is a really awesome framework
for writing web apps in Python and so I
know this talk is that like an
intermediate level and I'm going to talk
about some more like intermediate things
but just so we're on the same page if
you have a model or results you're a
data scientist and you want people to be
able to access those or whatever but you
don't want them to have to download and
install something themselves you want to
serve up these results or the internet
flask is a great framework for doing
that and there are tons of beginner
tutorials on the internet aimed at just
getting started with using flask so I'm
not going to go over those things but
just know that there are tons of them
out there you can just google data
scientist flask tutorial so I'm going to
talk about some of the more advanced
things that you can do and then there's
G unicorn that is a product quality
Python web server gateway interface so
it's so a web server that you have to
put in front so you define everything in
flask and then you need a web server to
actually create that connection to the
user flask does have a built-in web
server and a lot of the beginner
tutorials use that but it doesn't scale
well and even in Flast zone Doc's they
say not to use
so which is true like it just doesn't
scale well it's really good for
prototyping but then if you want to
actually put something in production I
guess my first tip for you is to not use
the built in flask whatsoever to use
something like Chi uniform so one issue
that will come up if you're a data
scientist and you have a model and it
gives results and you want to know if
you should either pre compute every
possible thing that your API might
return and store it in a database or do
you want to say have a machine learning
model in a container and then run the
users data through that at request time
so there are different situations where
one might be optimal over the other but
you want to ask yourself is there a
fixed universe of things that you could
conceive what we want to pass into your
model and if it's true that there is a
well contained fixed universe of
possible parameters then it couldn't
make sense to just put them all through
the model pre compute it store it in a
database because then the latency will
not be as much of an issue it's much
easier just query the database and get
those results or it's usually easier
than to actually run a machine learning
model at request time so the latency can
be a big issue there so a few examples
where you may want to pre compute
everything so one example of that is the
trending service that I've been talking
about because it's just like a feed of
things and it's really hard to say give
me like number 10,000 of the trending
feed like there's no like model that
takes in that number it's just a list of
things that I've pre computed you also
could have say collaborative filtering
recommendation systems where you're
trying to figure out what products might
be similar to other products based on
who's purchased or viewed them in the
past and that's another situation where
it's very timely and costly to compute
that so you want to just do it all at
once overnight and just store it but
then there are a lot of examples where
you don't want to do that or you can't
even do that
so examples would be where someone might
give you data point that they want a
result for that you've never seen before
so
that could be a customer lifetime value
model where a lot of the features are
floats or a computer vision model like
there are some that we're building a
shop runner where for example someone
will give you an image and you give them
back
similar looking images that's a sort
situation where like you can't just
compute for every possible image you
could receive that's something where you
have to compute it at runtime and then
if you are complete computing and
putting things in a database you to
choose between no sequel database or a
sequel database no sequel databases can
be great if you can easily store it
everything as key value pairs but if
there's any kind of filtering that
you're going to want to do you really
want to put things in a sequel database
so I'm gonna walk through now for the
next 15 minutes some examples of these
tips and tricks for building a
production system in flask and this is
kind of like a sandbox scenario that I'm
gonna be using for all of my examples
and this is extreme toy version of the
trending service so on the left side I
have a schematic of a sequel database
where I'm storing results so let's say
once a night I have a data job that runs
in data breaks and it computes what's
trending for that day and it appends
this table with the new set of trending
results along with some sort of
timestamp or date column and then when
we do that there's also a run parameters
table that lives in that same database
where I am logging information about
each run so the most crucial piece of
information that I'm going to talk about
today is the date at which the run
happened so this results table is
getting larger I'm constantly appending
to it I probably want to have some way
of cleaning it up too so I'm not just
keeping results forever but as I append
to it I want to log like when the last
append was in a really easy to use data
in a really easy to use data table like
a very tiny params table it's very easy
to query and that just gives me speed
and then on the right side I'm writing
out some of the
that I will have for this there's a
filtered request module and that does a
few things for me I'm going to define a
filtered request class and I'm going to
show you in a couple slides I have some
functions that will compose sequel
queries for me depending on like what
query parameters people give me and then
function to format the results before I
send them back to the user and then that
gets imported by the main app module and
that's a PI so in there I have the app
config with flask I figure out all the
logging I can figure that there's a
bunch of nice error handling you can do
in flask so I'm going to talk about and
then I've functions that define all the
different endpoints that I'm going to
have so for example one endpoint I'm
going to have is let's say you want the
10th most trending item today you give
me the number 10 and I return to you
information about that item so my first
piece of advice that I have is that if
you're gonna be using sequel a sequel
database destroy your results because
maybe you want to be able to bunch
filtering like with the trending service
sequel alchemy a flat sequel alchemy is
really awesome so if you have like a web
app and a web server and you have
database connections it can be kind of
overwhelming to know like how exactly to
maintain those database connections like
what happens when you lose your
connection like how do you start a new
one that's kind of stuff can get kind of
overwhelming to the data scientist but
if you use Flass sequel alchemy it
actually handles all that stuff for you
so I'm just showing you here like an
extremely simple way that you would
start your app so this could be like the
top of my app pie file where I just
compose a database URI based on a bunch
of credentials that I have in a
configuration file and then I set what's
called the sequel alchemy database URI
part of this app config so app config is
just something that flask has
to just store all the configurations of
your application and this is just a
predefined thing that it uses for flat
sequel alchemy so you just feed that the
database URI and then you can define or
instantiate this DB object which then
you'll use for all of your queries going
forward in your app another tip is to
use one logging handler so if you have a
a web app it could have many different
pieces of it that have different loggers
involved different loggers that they use
and it's really helpful to take all
those logs and put them all in the same
place and you can do that by taking
advantage of what are called handlers
that the logging objects have so here
what I'm doing is I'm combining the logs
from both the flask app itself which has
its own logging and then G unicorn which
is my web server which also has its own
logging and so you can find the logger
for G unicorn and then set the app
handler to be equal to that Handler and
then all those logs will go to the same
place and then you can also have or you
should also have different environments
for your applications so you're building
consumer product you have a concept of
the production app but you don't want to
push new changes directly to that so
you'll have the concept of a whip
environment or a staging environment for
trying things out before they actually
get pushed out to customers and so you
can have different logging levels for
different environments so for whip you
might want a logging level of debug
because you want to see every single
thing that can go wrong but then for
production you probably want to reduce
that logging level because you don't
want to just be overwhelmed with too
much logging another thing that was
non-obvious to us when building this
application is what happens when we're
updating the data so one thing that you
definitely don't want to do is you have
a table of data results
that your app is pulling from and you
want to update it so you drop that table
and you build a new table that's not a
good thing to do because when that table
doesn't exist your API is not going to
have any data to access and then
everything will fail so you need some
way of updating your data and then
logging information about the data
update in a way that the app can use so
again I'm using the app config for this
so again app dot config is you can store
anything in there you want and so what
I'm doing in this get date function here
is storing the date of the most recent
data update so if you remember from my
toy example before this data set gets
updated every day by appending a data
table but things can go wrong there
there could be that something breaks in
the data job and the data didn't
actually get updated that day so you
can't always assume that the date that
you query for in your API is gonna be
today or whatever the most you know
yesterday if it runs at night so this is
a good way to log that information so
that your app has access to it so what
this code here does is it stores two
things
it stores something called current date
which is the current date that you
that's a date you want to query for in
your sequel and then there's something
called last update so it's telling you
the last time you checked that
information and it's making use of this
params table that I mentioned before
that stores all the parameters about
every run of this data job so I just go
to this tiny little easy to query table
that I have I query it for whatever the
current data is and then I just store
that information so then in my API what
I'm defining my endpoints I just access
this config or I can run this get date
function I get this date every time so
then I can put that in my queries
another thing that really helped us a
lot we first didn't do this but then
eventually ended up doing it because
there are just so many different query
parameters that ended up coming coming
into our JIRA backlog and so it's it
became way easier to maintain the code
by creating this filtered request class
so this trending feed if you want to
personalize it for customers you might
want to filter it by what department you
want to shop in like men's women's
children you might want to filter it by
like what city you live in or what zip
code you're in maybe min and Max price
or some things on sale there's this this
exploding list of query parameters that
someone might want to give us when they
access the API so this class does a lot
of things for us to keep our code tidy
so when you instantiate one of these
things a filtered request object
you give it several things you give it
the DB object so you tell it with
database to use here you'll see there's
an offset in a limit those are for
pagination so in sequel if you do a
sequel query you could get a tremendous
number of things back and so let's say I
just want item 0 through 20 or 1 through
20 then I make the offset equal to 0 and
the limit equal to 20 but now let's say
I want the next 20 I want the second
page now limit is still 20 but now
offset is also 20 and then you can just
keep incrementing the offset by whatever
page size you want so those are two
things that the user gives us um and
then also in flask you can have query
parameters that are either just one
thing at a time so I'm saying you need
give me just one city you can't have
multiple cities just one city at a time
but you can also have some parameters
that are lists so maybe you might want a
whole list of retailers let's say
there's a product that uses trending
where customer gives them a list of
their favorite retailers and so they
want to filter down this list to that
list of favorite retailers and so you
look at the request arguments and you
can just get one or you think
list and then in this class there will
be a bunch of methods to query the
database so you'll format a bunch of
sequel based on these queries and then
format the response that you'll give
back and so then how using this would
look in the actual flask app PI module
where you're actually defining your
endpoints let's say you have a results
endpoint here so what you do is you look
at request dot args or just like the
request thing that's telling you all the
query parameters that the user has given
you and then you can parse that out in
flask and then create this request
object that's this one of these filtered
requests so if you see here there's
requests arts or as the current date I'm
using that get date function to figure
out what date I wanted my sequel queries
I'm getting the offset in the limit from
the user and then building this request
and then let's say the filtered request
class has a get results function so like
I'm just using that to get what I'm
going to return to the user one big
gotcha here with doing filtered requests
in flask is that there are URI limits
and they depend on what browser you're
using but 2,000 characters is a pretty
safe bet so you want to keep the URI
below 2,000 characters but then let's
say someone wants to give you a giant
list of query parameters well then that
might not be less than 2,000 characters
and it won't work so what you can do is
instead of a get request which is what
most of this will be someone's getting
data from me you can do what's called a
post type of request so with this code
here does is it allows for both gets and
posts depending on how the user wants to
use a API and then it checks to see you
with request method it checks to see if
it's a poster again so if it's a post
I'm saying okay this is gonna be a JSON
request and I need to parse the JSON if
it's not a post then I'm assuming it's a
get
it's not a JSON request and I can just
get request args in the standard way
these are all very standard flask
objects that are at your disposal to do
this there was like really not much
boilerplate that I had to do before this
another thing that can be tricky to the
data scientist who's not you know a
back-end engineer is what exactly is she
should be status codes mean and they
like exactly how to return an
informative error message it's very easy
within flask to define different error
handlers so you see the decorator app
dot error handler what I'm defining here
is an error handler for a 400 West and
as a data scientist that's going to be
probably the status code aside from a
200 that you'll use the most is when
people try to use your API incorrectly
so what you can do is just define a bad
request function like this that takes in
the error and it looks at the error
description and it just returns that to
the user and the response so what this
will do is like let's say someone tries
to request more than a hundred items and
I've decided that that's not okay if
limit is greater than 100 I'm gonna use
the flask abort function with a 400 when
it sees the 400 it looks for this error
handler and it returns what this error
handler prescribes so return of 400 code
and then this message that I encoded in
here cannot request more than 100 items
so you can look at all the different
edge cases things you don't want your
user to do and define a function like
this also like couple other error codes
that are kind of confusing 404 not found
actually was in the middle of an
argument it was to back end engineers
arguing over what this means but
basically if you have an endpoint that
does not like someone tries to hit an
endpoint that doesn't exist so let's say
we have a retailer's endpoint and
someone tries to go to retailer slash
ABCD and that doesn't exist that would
be a legit use of 404 because that
point doesn't exist but then let's say
we have a queryable endpoint this
results endpoint and someone puts in a b
DS ABCD as a retailer that should
actually give you a 200 which is like
the good request like you did it right
message and an empty list because the
user used the api correctly it worked it
queried you just didn't find anything so
that actually is a legit thing and not a
404 not found whereas a 206 partial
content is also something a data
scientist prolly is never going to use
that's only to indicate when only a part
of the response has been returned and
it's only to use when your API intends
to return data and chunks when throttled
and then one last thing that I want to
talk about is issue of latency so this
isn't something when building this API I
first really thought very deeply about
of course I knew it we didn't want it to
take a really long time to run but I
didn't really think like of all the
consequences that would happen if it
wasn't actually super fast so latency
when your pre computing results is not
just about slowness but also about your
database load so if you write your
sequel queries in very inefficient ways
not only were your app be slow but your
database CPU might get overwhelmed and
then if you're using sequel definitely
don't use joins that will just make it
very slow it's it's better to just store
more data and actually pre join
everything you would want to and store
it that way then actually do a join in
your API build good indexes on any data
sources that is for no sequel and sequel
so the data is stored in the most
efficient manner for the API to access
it and then also you could add a cache
so this is something that we recently
tried with the trenny API there's query
caching that comes with some databases
where it just logs in a key value store
like what queries it's tried and what
the results are so it doesn't have to
bother the database you can add
something very similar yourself with a
key value store like say Redis
and then there are lots of settings to
whatever web server you're using that
you can play around with to help with
latency and so for example 4G unicorn
they have really good docs on all the
different things you can try so you can
change the number of workers or threads
they're different worker types like
synchronous and asynchronous it might
work for different use cases and then
there's also like timeout that you need
to tune for your particular use case so
just a recap everything that I've gone
over I want to say flask is great there
were a lot of like flask standard things
that come with a package that I was
using here so the app config ACK dot
request like there are lots of things
already built into flasks and make it
very easy to write to write up these
endpoints with not having to do a ton of
boilerplate yourself if you're doing pre
computed results and storing them in
this in a sequel database I also highly
recommend flask sequel alchemy cause
you'll handle also the boilerplate of
dealing with the sequel database
I would suggest using one logging
handler or at least thinking very
carefully about where exactly your logs
are going to make sure that in all your
different your development environment
and your production environment that
you're really seeing everything that's
going on you need to prevent downtime
whenever you're updating your data so I
encourage you to make use of the app
config that you can use in flask
to to store information about what data
set you can use and in creating
redundant data sets you can keep your
query handling code from getting out of
control by putting it into a class that
makes it much easier to maintain if you
have long lists of query parameters
there are query length limitations you
could bump up again so in that case use
a post instead of a get and then the
flask error handlers are very powerful
and they're great for building
informative custom error messages for
all the different HTTP status codes you
could come across and I encourage you to
actually research what the different
HTTP status codes me
because the idea is that this API you're
building for your data science is going
to be consumed by back-end developers
and if those HTTP status codes don't
make sense to what they think they
should mean then that'll make them sad
and not want to use your service and you
want them to like using your service
there's a few less cool things you
should look up postman so that's an API
development environment but it's really
good for like storing test queries and
test cases and sharing them to your
coworkers
swagger is a very popular way to build
documentation for api's and there's this
repo called flask er that you can use
that good it's like a combination of
swagger for flask so it's really easy to
get started with building swagger tasks
stocks in flask and then we use a two
dog a shop runner for all of our metrics
and monitoring it's been really useful
you can just add decorators to functions
that will log things for you and then
you can just build custom dashboards
those that you can monitor things like
like latency and different error codes
that have come up and you can even set
alarms it does like simple anomaly
detection on all these things that
you're monitoring so that's super useful
so that's it thank you very much again
come up to me at the end of the talk if
you want a free one-year membership
sharpener and does anybody have any
questions
[Applause]
they're microphones here yeah yeah so so
if you want to have a model that
actually I think that Nehemiah follows
but so for the example that I talked
about today everything's all the data
science all the pre-computation was done
like we did it in data bricks and then
from data bricks it's stored in the
sequel database and then the API doesn't
really do anything but book we redact
then let's say you have a model and you
want to run the users request through
your model when they're doing that you
can have your model just like have the
artifact of your model like pickle it
and have that artifact in a container
and then build that when you build your
service and then it's totally possible
to have that into to use it users
results at runtime but then there are
also services that do stuff like that
for you as well so I know AWS they have
like Amazon sage maker is something that
we've been using for our computer vision
code because it it like does a lot of
that stuff for you but and then if you
had computer vision mods you also use
tester for surveying like there are lots
of different frameworks that are built
to help you do that but it's basically
you can just have the model artifact and
then just run it in a docker container
and then when people give you parameters
they want to put into it just run the
model in the endpoint definition so or
you can have a separate module that does
those things and then feeds it and then
that gets imported into app top I if you
want to keep them separate
okay I yeah so this is Lake and that was
a new thing to me and I just kind of put
it out there it's like an extra because
I can't speak authoritative Leon it like
what other alternatives did you like
better
black flask rebar okay and that's like a
documentation like an automatic
documentation service that does it build
swagger Docs okay okay cool so if anyone
didn't hear that
like flask er is not the only option out
there to build swagger docks with the
flask API there are other options out
there that might be simpler and better
suited to your needs then I'm not aware
of including flasks rebar yes okay any
other questions no it's really late
all right thank you
[Applause]